welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and the original x-men film
defines so much of marvel adaptations
for years to come
as the launch of young associate
producer kevin feige
with the genius chemistry between
gandalf jean-luc picard
and russell crowe's friend from the cast
of oklahoma x-men embraced the comic
steeper themes of prejudice and
alienation so that 20 years later we can
forgive the black leather jumpsuits as
baby steps before marvel perfected
rugged desaturation
after several months of requests let us
now do a scene-by-scene
deep dive for all the interesting visual
details cameos and hidden layers of
meaning that you might have missed over
the past two decades these subtle ways
x-men's greatness became the mcu's
greatness during the opening 20th
century fox fanfare remember that
the x of the fox logo stays illuminated
briefly as we fade to black
a little detail that they edited into
many following x-men films all the way
through dark phoenix last year the
soothing voice of patrick stewart
narrates about mutation
while these white lights swirl past each
other but every few hundred millennia
evolution leaps forward yeah this 90s
screensaver [ __ ]
represents the x gene that links all the
mutants via cerebro we are in the mind
of charles xavier in this moment as he's
trying to reach out to the other side of
this movie's big debate
eric lyncher magneto which is why the
door of cerebro
is locking away eric's tragic origin
separated from his family at auschwitz
young eric uses the power of metal
manipulation to bend the gates into a
crude
x-shape an interesting bit of
parallelism with charles xavier's
x-door leading to cerebro that this
memory is locked away within for
eric the number tattoo and the smoke
from the auschwitz chimney forever
link him to all the oppressed souls that
humanity has scattered in a diaspora
and when charles uses cerebro to track
mutants they do
appear lost and scattered within a smoky
haze
but speaking of the dangers of evolution
thanks to dodo peak for sponsoring this
video
dodo peak is a new retro-inspired arcade
action platformer
made by move-in pieces it is out on
nintendo switch for 9.99
and is available on the nintendo switch
eshop in dota peak you play as a dodo
bird trying to save her baby birds from
falling rocks
slytherin snakes lava and more maybe
there's a reason these birds went
extinct in real life they were
surrounded by danger the game's got that
old school gameplay design that feels
familiar
and the new school upgrades and styling
to make it feel really modern
it's easy to pick up but challenging to
master so you'll be able to save those
baby dodos as much as you want there's
also lots of unlockables to keep
gameplay fresh
unlock new dodos to help you beat the
challenges at different levels
just like how i wear different shorts
for the challenges of sitting or
standing or zoom calling with the same
person two days in a row be sure to
check out dodo peak available now on the
nintendo switchy shop for 9.99
one of those lost souls is rogue in the
not too distant future
though later films in the very confusing
x-men timeline established this as a
2000. up the canadian rockies i want to
be kind of cold
well that's the point stupid rogue's
dream trip with her boyfriend
is what leads her up to the canadian
rockies where she runs into wolverine
the filmmakers chose to lead with the
origin stories of magneto and rogue to
frame x-men as a story
of prejudice and alienation the horrors
of world war ii
and a teenage girl who can never touch
anyone both underline how superheroes in
these movies
are kind of having fun and that
political reality continues with gene
grey's senate speech over mutant
registration
senator kelly showboats i have here a
list of names
of identified mutants a girl in illinois
who can walk through walls
now what's to stop her from walking into
the white house of course he's referring
to kitty pride shadow cat who does show
up later in this film
and an x2 and then recast as ellen page
in the last stand
and indeed x2 does open with a mutant
attack on the white house
a very sick attack really senator kelly
is invoking senator joe mccarthy during
his infamous communist witch-hunts of
the 50s when he blustered that he had in
his hand a list of known communist
infiltrators in the government
originally stan lee based the mutant
debate and his comics on the civil
rights movement of the 60s which we see
in a dialogue between charles and eric
these two's relationship was inspired by
the relationship between dr martin
luther king jr and malcolm x
with king preaching non-violent
legislative progress like charles does
and malcolm x preferring more radical
revolution like eric does yet ultimately
both men wanted the same thing which the
camera work reflects here with eric and
charles with the framing
both men are framed on the side as they
speak to each other their visions
aligned on the same vector but their
means to that end
cast in different lights charles in open
truthful sunlight eric
in dark shadow the truck driver who
drops off rogue is george busa who
voiced beast in the x-men animated
series
and here we meet logan cage fighting as
the wolverine he's got the hair the dog
tags the sagar already comic fans were
like
yes with each of his hits the sound
mixer snuck in a metallic
clank
[Applause]
and teen at the adamantium on his bones
and the pain both fighters must feel
during this
they even mix in a metallic grind when
logan stretches his neck
[Applause]
logan's coat backstory is later shown
when it's given to him in x-men origins
wolverine and when he sneaks on the sore
loser
i love the close-up on his middle claw
as it pushes out of his knuckle skin
but again these powers aren't fun well
they are for us
but not for these characters when they
come out
does it hurt every time and without
looking logan
slices the shotgun through the stock
without clipping the guy's arm
piercing the shell to spill the buckshot
so logan
sliced this so cleanly that it would not
ignite the round
this angry punch pulling is key
to wolverine's character hugh jackman
said that he took cold showers every
morning at dawn
biting his tongue to keep him from
yelping and waking his wife all to prep
himself
as a deadly warrior who could massacre a
room but
must restrain himself as kevin feige
would later reply to iron man it's not
about the boom
it's more badass to attack but with
surgical restraint
and compare wolverine's smoothness here
with the opening scene of his final film
logan he is so beaten down that when he
slices that shotgun
he recklessly cuts the guy's arm off so
that the guy's finger is still in the
trigger and it fires blasting logan's
car
amazing attention to detail by that
director james mangled to call that back
in logan
rogue stows away in logan's trailer i
saved your life
you didn't he's right logan would have
survived the sword loser stab but
rogue does see his true power in the
flesh during sabretooth's attack and she
learns that his claws and fighting
skills aren't powers themselves their
consequences of his real power are
healing
and she gets a fuller complete before
and after picture of this walking weapon
with a deeper darker past than she can
ever
really know storm and cyclops save him
but logan's truck and trailer explode
destroying his motorcycle which is
probably why logan feels no shame
stealing cyclops's motorcycle later
and again at the end of the film and we
meet magneto's brotherhood of mutants
first with toad
darth maul actor ray park seen with his
eyes bigger via goggles like a
toad and he's spraying this metal copper
green this is the
piece of the statue of liberty that they
later use to conceal magneto's
conversion device
magneto has some newton's cradle balls
but notice they're swinging without
strings he's doing this with his mind it
presumably is a kind of stress ball
exercise
and he compares wolverine's dog tag
number to his own wrist tattoo but it's
a little misdirect to make us
think that magneto has an interest in he
and logan's parallel dark war histories
and logan's
metallic skeleton but really it's just a
fleeting fancy by the old man
rogue is his true target at the
x-mansion logan meets charles who
now that he's safe home away from the
judgy senators he wears his pride with
an
x-pin on his tie and his students here
are all mutants we know
jubilee recast for x2 and then again an
apocalypse mirage danny moonstar
who will be the central figure to the
upcoming new mutants film pyro who was
also recast next to
iceman bobby drake and this movie's
shadow cat kitty pride notice how the
chalkboard depicts refraction of light
through a curved lens it's a little
foreshadowing of the tactic that they
will use to redirect cyclops's optic
blast on sabertooth in the final battle
as aurora monroe storm halle berry tried
to use a kenyan accent to reflect the
character's african ancestry in the
first film but she dropped it in later
films thank god she's all right
she's just upset angela bassett was
actually originally considered for the
role
which would have been amazing but she
did go on to later play queen of wakanda
in the mcu in black panther now both
storm and cyclops had
scripted but never shot origin scenes
aurora accidentally destroying her
hometown in kenya with violent weather
and scott destroying his high school
bathroom with a scene that was actually
included for scott's origin
in x-men apocalypse colossus peter
rasputin makes a quick appearance
sketching by the pond
and pyro and iceman compete for rogue's
attention during class
now notice storm's chalkboard describes
the history of the roman empire
and a removed extended version of her
lecture has an interesting detail
the roman empire for centuries they
persecuted and ostracized the christians
almost overnight their religion rose to
become
the dominant faith of the empire does
anyone know
what suddenly caused the christians to
become accepted
the emperor became christian exactly
right
emperor constantine and his ruling class
all converted
magneto's plan is exactly what the
persecuted christians of ancient rome
used on charlemagne converting the
ruling class to make the rulers just
like them
eventually overturning the power
structure so that christianity would go
on to
dominate the western world for hundreds
of years and this chalkboard foreshadows
that threat
whereas charles's chalkboard foreshadows
how they overcome it
the brotherhood kidnapped senator kelly
with his aide henry guy rich also from
the comics revealed as the imposter
mystique
[Music]
composer michael caiman used a cello
over mystique's theme for its
fierceness and eroticism han zimmer and
tina guo actually later applied the same
principle using the cello for the iconic
one
and magneto later reveals that mystique
was playing the long game here
mr guy rich has been dead for some time
senator and if you listen closely to the
final minutes of the movie
a news report explains what they did to
the real guy rich
a bear sounds like sabertooth wrecked
guy rich so the x-men analyzed
wolverine's anatomy
experimentation on mutants
it's not unheard of but i've never seen
anything like this
before now x-men first class later kind
of retconned this with
younger charles and eric briefly finding
logan in the early 60s though weapon x
would have wiped logan's memories and
charles probably wouldn't have known the
full details of logan's surgeries at
that point
go [ __ ] yourself scott and logan butt
heads i must just burn you up that a boy
like me saved your life
he calls himself a boy because there was
some removed dialogue from the spat
some mutants take pride in their gifts
especially those of us who are willing
to fight for what we believe in
never seen real combat boy logan
accidentally stabs rogue but she absorbs
his healing abilities
actually in the x-men comics rogue's
powers of flight super strength all the
other [ __ ] she can do actually came from
her doing this same thing to miss marvel
leading to some theories that captain
marvel 2 in the mcu
might introduce carol danvers
relationship with rogue the brotherhood
uses magneto's machine to convert
senator kelly into a mutant
transforming his flesh into that of a
jellyfish and the first thing he sees
when he washes up on a beach is a kid
cruelly poking a jellyfish little
microcosm of how humankind
would now treat him cameoine on the
beach is our man stanley
his first appearance in a marvel movie
after many marvel tv cameos and a cameo
and blade that was cut
gary goddard also came he was here but i
don't really care logan tracks down
rogue
the first boy i ever kissed i can still
feel him
inside my head and it's the same with
you
yeah solid writing here she means i also
feel your presence in my head logan but
it rings true for logan
because he also carries his countless
victims with him in his conscience
a cryptic guilt that cuts right through
his amnesia
that clouds the specifics of his victims
but magneto attacks
whoever said i wanted you yeah a solid
twist
reframing this from wolverine's story
back to the alienated girl that we
started with rogue
magneto threatens the cops dropping
their cars and pointing their own guns
back at them he
so clearly relishes being able to flex
like this after he and charles had to
hide in the sidelines in the shadows
as those who thought they were in power
debated their rights
storm watches helplessly as senator
kelly bloats into a water balloon and
pops
with a great sound effect of kelly
gargling and drowning on his own body
water
digital domain special effects director
shaun c cunningham said that they
considered
showing kelly's internal organs during
this transformation but
concluded it would be too gruesome but
not for our editors
the final act moves on to liberty island
where db sweeney cameos is a park guard
along with tom desanto the film's
executive producer later the guard who
finds mystique in disguise is another
cameo the movie's co-writer david hater
and the x-men suit up you actually go
outside in these things
what would you prefer yellow spandex
now in fairness x-men comics authorities
stan lee chris claremont they supported
this change to black
agreeing that bright blue and yellow
might be a bit impractical though
tell that to the cast who managed to get
one take of them hopping over the
barrier but otherwise
really struggle to move in these times
oh my god whoa that's insane nobody can
move in there
mystique hides in plain sight as a
smaller statue of liberty and i love
that she's right there in the middle of
the lobby when they first enter just
behind scott the moment wolverine uses
his middle claw to flip him off
it's this moment when mystique reads
logan's appearance and his claws so that
she can copy him
and then seconds later after logan
wanders off you can see
the moment mystique behind a different
column shape-shifts into wolverine where
her arm
shuts out of the shadows right before
approaching the others to try to trick
them
20 years before we had cat versus cab
this movie delivers it here with
wolverine vs wolverine and there's more
solid attention to detail
of wolverine's real adamantium claws
sharper than mystique's
false copies he's only his or true
adamantium
and during the fight there's another
metallic ping when mystique kicks his
gut
now the reason mystique screamed in pain
when wolverine cut her claws is that
when she's finally beaten notice how she
chaotically shifts again and her claws
come back out
though they morph back into what look
like fingers so it was part of her flesh
that logan cut earlier that's why she
was in pain toad battles gene
and storm with ray park twirling the
staff and a self-homage to his mall
moves and then
this infamous moment do you know what
happens to a toad when it struck by
lightning
the same thing that happens to
everything else avengers director joss
whedon was one of the writers who did a
pass on the script
and this was one of the jokes that he
wrote along with this one
hey hey it's me prove it
you're a dick okay and according to
whedon in an interview after this movie
came out that toad lightning joke was
cringy
because he said he wrote it to be
sarcastic kind of like know what happens
to a tube and gets struck by lightning
same thing that happens to everything
else but that berry was misdirected to
deliver it with like zero irony same
thing that happens to
everything else and i love this history
because it's like an early shot in the
nerd wars that we wage 20 years later
joss whedon as a superhero movie
director definitely works best when he's
directing his own scripts wolverine
battles sabertooth on the statue liberty
crown
swinging around a spike in a move that
marvel would later use for black panther
they blast sabertooth they save
rogue as magneto's machine gives her her
signature silver hair streak and as the
mutant conversion shockwave fades
banky jansen makes an awesome acting
choice that i never noticed until now
now earlier charles speculated that this
device had no effect on mutants
yet it does stir something inside jane
here
and in x2 she and scott referenced this
moment i wasn't really sure how to say
this but
ever since liberty island been
even different so yeah right here we are
seeing the moment the phoenix force
reawakens inside gene logan heads off to
alkali lake in the canadian rockies to
investigate his weapon x past
and they realize that mystique lives on
disguised as senator kelly
but on to the amazing final scene this
movie opened with charles using cerebro
to reach out to eric and it bookends
with these two old friends playing chess
reflecting their roles as movement
leaders
sacrificing their foot soldiers in this
ongoing war
doesn't even wake you in the middle of
the night the feeling that someday they
will come for you
and your children it does indeed
what do you do when you wake up to that
i feel a great swell of pity for the
poor soul who comes to that school
looking for trouble actually x-men
apocalypse ends by referencing this same
exchange
doesn't it ever wake you up in the
middle of the night the feeling that one
day they'll come for you
and your children it does indeed
what do you do when you wake up to that
i feel a great swell of pity for the
poor soul that comes to my school
looking for trouble indeed their fears
come to pass in x2 when striker leads
the charge
to the school actually a real-life chess
master working with 538 analyzed charles
and eric's end games in this game of
chess
and their strategies fascinatingly
reflect their characters ideologies
eric overvalues his more powerful pieces
but
charles is more willing to sacrifice his
pieces even having given up his queen
and relies on simple pawns to box in
eric similar to his character's trust in
humans to help him
in his victory both men are imperfect
charles lets many of his beloved
warriors die in the battles to come
but his faith in all people powerful
pieces and pawns
mutants and humans strong and weak
ultimately
reward his hope ah 20 years later i
loved revisiting the film that started
it all and taught kevin feige so much
about how to make his mcu as great as it
is
so much of this film's devout fan
service came from this young associate
producer which is why i am so excited to
see his take on these mutants now that
he can introduce them in his cinematic
universe
join us on our official discord server
for our next watch along by becoming a
patron at patreon.comrockstars follow me
on instagram at eavos follow new
rockstars and subscribe for breakdowns
of everything you love
that definitely avoid mentioning the
director who we later found out as a
terrible human being bye
[Music]
you